[Music]
if you're hungry for song birds and
snakes whatever that means then we've
got you covered this week along with
four other delicious pics along with the
return of The Hunger Games franchise
we've got the return of the Godzilla
franchise the return of the Scott
Pilgrim franchise the return of a
royally popular Netflix franchise and
the return of the trolls franchise I'm
sensing a theme for you whatever and
it's all coming up on this week's what
to watch there has been a change this
year as a mentor Mr snow Your Role is to
turn these children into spectacles not
survivors arriving in theaters is The
Hunger Games The Ballad of song birds
and snakes that's right the franchise is
back on the big screen for the first
time in 8 years after Jennifer Lawrence
starred in four movies ending with
mocking jay part two in 2015 that's
reason number one to check this one out
the second is that this movie is once
again based on Suzanne Collins novel The
Ballad of song birds and snakes
naturally which is a prequel of The
Hunger Games and set 64 years before the
events of the first film it Chronicles
how the the character Cory Alanis snow
got on a course for tyranny and while
it's an allnew cast for this fifth
installment that cast has some great
names in its own right and is good
enough for reason three I'm talking
Rachel zler Peter Dinklage Viola Davis
and Jason schwarzman to name a few when
the whole city was coming
down these guys were taking pictures
like they'd been waiting for it smashing
and crashing its way on a Apple TV plus
is the new series Monarch Legacy of
Monsters the first reason to check this
one out is that it's based in the world
of Godzilla in fact it follows the
events of the 2014 Godzilla movie and
features an organization that encounters
Godzilla and other big monsters called
Titans and while the cast includes
talented folks like kiry Clemens and
John Goodman the real second reason to
watch Monarch Legacy of monsters is that
it's a family affair as in Kurt Russell
and his son Wyatt Russell both Star as
older and younger versions of the same
character something the critics
consensus says works like a charm the
third reason to watch is the strong
Talent behind the scenes scenes with
Creator Chris Black coming from shows
like Desperate Housewives Star Trek
Enterprise and Xena Warrior Princess
plus we know the first two episodes were
directed by Matt shakman whose resume
includes Fargo Game of Thrones W divion
and the upcoming Fantastic 4 movie it's
time to wake up
here I had a dream about that girl again
I didn't care the first time he told me
care even less now another streaming
option for you this week is the new
series Scott Pilgrim takes off on
Netflix once again based on the graphic
novels by Brian Lee om Ali who also
helped develop the series the first
reason to tune in is that it's now gone
from graphic novel to liveaction film to
anime series how cool is that even
cooler and this is reason to is that the
entire cast from the 2010 film Scott
Pilgrim versus the world is reprising
their roles for this if you need a
refresher that includes Michael Sarah as
Scott Pilgrim plus Mary Elizabeth
Winstead Kieran culen Chris Evans Anna
Kendrick Brie Larson Aubrey Plaza and so
many more and speaking of that 2010
flick that last last reason to give this
one a try is that the movie much like
the graphic novels themselves was a
certified fresh hit with a strong
audience score and so with the same cast
and Creator no reason why this can't be
loved by all am I right don't really
understand how I ended up
[Music]
here dashing
around losing sight of myself in the
process another Netflix option for you
this week is the return of the drama
series The Crown first up the main
reason to check out this dramatic take
on real events is that it marks the
sixth and final season of the show which
will be released in two parts with four
episodes now and the final six in a few
weeks another reason is that the final
season is expected to cover topics like
the deaths of Princess Diana and the
Queen Mother the early days of William
and Kate and the Premiership of Tony
Blair bring on all the drama the last
reason to try on this Crown is that the
previous five fresh seasons have all
done well with critics with four of the
five coming in certified fresh not to
mention it has a whole trophy room full
of Emmys including outstanding drama
series and 2021 baby Branch I'm John
Dory Branch's brother what ow former
brother drama bringing a splash or
perhaps a few truckloads of bright
colors to theaters is the animated flick
trolls ban together the first reason to
sing along with this one is that the
franchise is on a roll the two previous
films from 2016 and 2020 were popular
with fans and critics not to mention
they put out two different popular
animated series on Netflix and peacock
in that time as well the second reason
to enjoy trolls band together is just
that they're getting the band back
together well figuratively speaking aka
the corecast of stars Justin Timberlake
and Anna Kendrick are returning and
they're joined by newcomers like Amy
Schumer deid Diggs kid cudy and Eric
Andre the third reason to check it out
and this is the big one is that they're
getting the band back together literally
speaking too that's because in sync has
recorded an original song for the film
their first new track in 22 years so I
guess bye bye bye we're all head to to
the theater well that's it five picks
that will be sure to fill you up this
week we're on that Thanksgiving pregame
be sure to let us and your fellow
viewers know in the comments what you
did check out whether it was on this
list or not remember to check out rot
tomatoes.com for the latest updates on
scores and reviews for everything
mentioned as well as the movie and TV
World At Large that's all for today
fresh family until next week stay
freshh